foreign
thank you pleasure to be here so you're
a philosopher of science with a strong
interest in cosmology what first spot
you're interested in cosmology and was
it because logic that motivated an
interesting philosophy of science or was
it the other way around it was actually
the other way around I studied the
historical and logical foundations for
metaphysics I was always interested in
this crossing over between like the
limit space between what we can know and
what we believe so the crossover where
science and religion meet and so I was
digging into I had a chance to research
from different theoretical perspectives
and overlap sort of history of how we
came to uh construct our theories of the
world and how we came to understand
things in a modern scientific sense
and then increasingly I became focused
on
cosmology it started with with physics I
had my first research question was about
the Large Hadron Collider and how we
could possibly know
or claim that in the experiment
underground in the tunnel outside of
Geneva could somehow explain things at a
universal level
and I just asked it very naively as an
outsider as a kind of question like okay
what accounts for that how do we know
this and so on but gradually as I did
more studies of theoretical physics and
those foundations and then
I became increasingly concerned with
cosmology being you know the most uh
the most severely limited science from a
scientific point of view where it's most
obvious that you have to make inferences
and assumptions and so I became very
interested in
how the science operates as a science
and pretends not to do metaphysics
and so
from that perspective I was able to
raise some critical or skeptical
objections to the foundation of that as
a as a science as well and how do you
understand this kind of relationship
between philosophy and Sciences
philosophy there to kind of reflect on
what this thing that we call science is
it kind of dispels some
false beliefs that people have about how
social science is for example or is
there a space for philosophy influencing
for example how science
well I mean it's a it's a it's a product
of a certain history and this is what
actually interested me in the first
place is how did we get into the
situation where philosophy and science
are almost like two solitudes uh Because
the actual Foundation of modern science
before we called it modern science in
the 1700s and 1800s it was called
natural philosophy philosophy and
science were very much aligned from the
beginning and all the classical
scientists through James Kirk Maxwell up
through Einstein would have some degree
of philosophy background or something
and not just purely focused on physics
but something happened on both fronts in
the 20th century and you can start
marking it back to around 1920s 1930s
and on the physics side there was a
professionalization of physics became a
professional discipline where
you would basically only learn physics
and not so much philosophy so physics
set itself loose from philosophy and at
the same time philosophy went through
its own breaks in a sense it got kind of
lost in the woods and in the the tricky
question for philosophy was what role it
should serve or had to have relative to
science because science was emerging as
a new dominant way of knowing
increasingly had less uh uh use for
philosophy there was a famous or
inFAMOUS debate between Einstein and Ali
baxon or bergson in the 1920s which I
take to be sort of the marker aware the
shift happened between science and
philosophy because they were Einstein
bergson were basically debating the
nature of time and bergson had
a sort of a complementary view of time
to physical time as Einstein described
it and was trying to Advocate that there
is a different pers like a different uh
model of time that is also useful
and Einstein to put it crudely had no uh
interest in this whatsoever and he says
physics has no use for the time of
philosophers we have our own conception
so you could mark this as a time when
when physics kind of broke free of
philosophy and broke free of metaphysics
and took on the assumption that it's
possible to do science without
metaphysics
and then meanwhile in in philosophy uh
you had increasingly either an analytic
school that were trying to be useful to
science and then the work of that kind
of philosophy became focused on trying
to clarify Concepts and make scientific
work uh better and another Camp that's
sometimes called Continental School
which went wading into extential
questions and things that had no direct
correlate to science so in my view
something was lost and broken
in this and that has persisted through
almost a century of the lacking
discourse between science and philosophy
uh a lot of the philosophy of the last
50 years has been either of these two
either it's an exist in a space that is
has nothing useful to say to scientists
or it's completely subservient to it and
doesn't actually ask critical questions
so most of your work when it comes to
scrutinizing uh science as you mentioned
comes in the area of cosmology and
particularly talk about the standard
model of cosmology can you tell us very
briefly what
yeah the standard model of cosmology is
sometimes called the Lambda CDM model
for the scientists who are deeply inside
of it sometimes the concordance model
this is a complicated Beast like I
describe it as a like multiple building
blocks on top of each other it's a
multifaceted Theory uh but the core of
it is a general relativity model that is
evolutionary in in scope in time there's
a linear illusionary model coupled with
this idea of a finite origin in time
with the big bang cosmology and this
came about in the 1920s and 1930s and it
was coupled with uh an Insight or a
discovery by Hubble that space appeared
to be expanding now this is a this was
an interpretation at the time of the
phenomena that they were seeing but it
became a consensus interpretation that
space is expanding and here was a model
that allowed for spatial expansion
uh so this model was very quickly within
a decade or so was able to
take over the entire sort of
cosmological scene prior to this we had
a completely different view of what the
universe would be like but this
mathematical model coupled with this uh
this idea of a finite origin in time or
a cosmic explosion which ran in parallel
to Nuclear Physics which was rising at
the time it captured the imagination of
a lot of people and it seemed to have a
solid theoretical framework
in that we have general relativity is
able to predict extremely precisely
within our own Galaxy or within our own
solar system
and so what they did with this cosmology
was to say this is now valid for the
entire universe
not just our own Galaxy
and then as you started developing this
further on this assumption and we were
able to make observations further and
further out and discovering more and
more and more galaxies then more and
more discrepancies started coming in
the observations that didn't fit with
what the theoretical model said so one
of the most famous examples of this is
dark matter
which emerged as an invention in the
1960s 1970s to this problematic
discrepancy that was uh that was showing
up everywhere and it was not just a
small deviation it was like a massive
Gap between what the galaxies appeared
to be
doing in the shape and the rotation
curves and what the model would predict
and so the standard model of cosmology
has from this core adding on a layer of
dark matter and then adding on another
block called inflation to explain the
beginning of time how that's possible
and then further on attacking on another
block called dark energy to explain how
possibly space is accelerating and not
just expanding
becomes kind of like a Jenga Tower it is
built on
a set of assumptions each of those
blocks is built on a set of inferences
that are
very difficult to test and so I think
cosmology has ended up in a situation in
the last century where it's become kind
of stuck with a model that is failing to
convince people that it could be the
right one
and stuck in a pattern where it has to
patch on every time it discovers a
deviation it seems to have to invent
something new in order to account for it
you've mentioned already you've hinted a
couple of kind of critiques how do you
think of those you think of them as
scientific critiques or do you think
everyone's kind of philosophical
observations and philosophical critiques
is a standard model I think the
observations and the critique that I can
come forth with is historically based
it's philosophically based and it's
trying to take an outside Observer look
in terms of possibility
of how well do we actually know how all
these things stack together but it's not
my role to judge the Merit of a
scientific theory that is for the
scientific community that is one
consequence of physics and philosophy
sort of breaking breaking apart so right
now we have a cosmologist or a scientist
more generally speaking are setting all
the terms for how to approach and
understand the universe and they're also
the ones who judge whether they think a
theory has more Merit or not to some
degree the core of the model is taken as
a matter of faith
and that if you are to question it
then you risk running a foul uh of a lot
of things regarding you know funding and
career and and so on
on the one hand especially if you are a
scientist you can build a career now on
challenging some of the upper blocks so
to speak for example Dark Matter there
is a real Challenger to this particular
part
but I find very few scientists are
willing to look at the more questionable
assumptions underneath the core building
blocks of how we got here in the first
place and the reason why it strikes me
is not because those blocks are so solid
and proven Beyond doubt when you look at
them closely it's more that if you are
to
put them into doubt or if they are
slightly wrong or if you're to remove
them then you lose the guiding structure
you have to make sense of the universe
it's like taking a framework away from a
scientist is the same as making them
blind like then we have nothing to guide
us by so I think that there is a there's
a tendency to want to cling on to the
basics because it becomes very difficult
to do scientific research it is much
more convenient to add things to the
model
and preserve the existing structure than
it is to radically rethink it
so in connection
in a recent interview you argued that
the standard neurological model relies
on us a physical assumptions
but it didn't sound like you meant that
necessarily as a machine I think it's
impossible to create a cosmology or to
have a cosmological understanding
without having made some metaphysical
assumptions to begin with
so even competing models before the Big
Bang Theory there was something called
the steady state theory that was
competing for a little while with the
Big Bang Theory
had his own metaphysical assumptions
this whole which was in that case an
unchanging universe so whatever we
observe is changing is actually being
recreated elsewhere
but it's one of the legacies of the
split between philosophy and Science in
the 20th century is a strand of thought
sometimes called logical empiricism or
positivism
which really greatly influenced science
into this uh Rise Of The Professional
School of of science is to believe that
science has to be free of metaphysics
and that it's the ideal is to have a
science that's uh pure without having to
make any such grounding claims or any
such framing devices so
in my view this is a delusion
and it would be much better if we could
speak openly about what the guiding
assumptions or the premises for a theory
are and speaking them openly instead of
trying to hide them away if you look at
scientific texts or any scientific
calculation if you look at Einstein's
own work on general relativity he has a
couple of pages describing the
assumptions or the principles that he
uses and then there's pages of
mathematical equations
now most physicists would be trained to
look at his math and then to train to
look at the field equations
and to kind of gloss over the
assumptions part but all of those
assumptions are themselves
Up For Debate or questionable they're
ways of framing the problem and I don't
think you can ever get around that
one very important uh principle that
connects general relativity to like
creates a cosmological model for it it's
uh is known as the cosmological
principle and that sounds very
uh elevated and fanciful but it's really
just to say that the universe is the
same in all directions
and its main function
is to be useful as a simplifying
assumption
is this uh is this cosmological
principle the same as saying there are
laws of nature that apply everywhere or
is it a slightly different or something
that's an even more fundamental claim
and in a way that is one of the key
tenets of standard cosmology is to say
that what we what we know with high
confidence within our own solar system
the loss that we have been able to
deduce from our little tiny corner of
the universe they apply
Across the Universe
and this may have made a lot of sense in
the 1920s 1930s and so on when this
theory was under formation
but as we have learned more about the
size and the scope and the vastness of
the cosmos it becomes more and more
untenable and the number of
contradictions start piling up as well
uh
there is something about this
um there's something about this core
assumption that the loss we have here
apply all across the universe which
ultimately rests on a kind of faith in
that mathematical laws are the same
everywhere they increasingly come under
scrutiny from empirical data and
observations
would it be possible to tell a
difference
that when when we have observations that
seem to contradict what we think of
nature
would we be able to tell the difference
between whether that means our laws of
nature are just wrong
or that just that bit of the universe
that we're observing has different for
the nation can we tell the data alone
tell us whether one or the other was the
case
that's an interesting question I think
that's where it becomes difficult with
cosmology
because
we lack
clear guide posts for how large-scale
like how large of the scale is the scale
part of the reason like part of the way
that we understand just the uh just the
sheer space alone and how we measure it
is we use light phenomena in the sky
certain stars or standard candles to use
them as guides for understanding how far
they are away
that in itself is Theory dependent
and especially if you look at something
like Supernova explosions are now used
as part of a guide post to indicate how
far is it to galaxies that are out in
space
that far
the further out you go the more model
dependent you become like you could have
huge variations of just the scale itself
depending on which model you choose to
calculate by
to put it this way we are a little bit
uh we are a little bit lost in the dark
without anything other than a map to
guide us and even if we know the map is
incorrect throwing the map out is also
something that most scientists would be
reluctant to do because we don't know
quite what to put in its place so
fumbling in the dark like this it gets
fussy the further out you go
what will the ship that you're
envisaging mean for how we understand
our place in the universe and what the
universe is going to turn out to be an
even stranger things
I mean this is the interesting thing the
shift that I was trying to describe I
think could be could be phrased as we
become better at better at mathematical
descriptions so we can create models
that better fit with observations that
can add in variability for certain uh
for certain factors we thought were
Universal before
but what we will end up with in this
vision is better and better
approximation between like we have a
complex theoretical model that aligns
better and better with observations but
what we're lacking is explanation
so if you take away dark matter for
example and you in search this
Challenger modified Newtonian Dynamics
you change the loss of gravitation
instead and you say dark matter doesn't
exist but here we tweaked the loss of
gravity to make the observations fit one
of the the risks surrounding the science
and the development of the science and
some of the I think the public is very
interested in cosmology generally it
seems to me
but it's very hard to access the theory
on a level that is understandable and
it's almost not understandable to
astrophysicists or cosmologists
themselves
there's a lot of questions at stake that
I think also need to be addressed and
maybe that's a space for philosophy to
enter as well but I don't think
scientists can explain
so thinking about philosophy of science
and technology is one aspect of what you
do another aspect is you write dramas
and thrillers for film and TV have you
ever thought about merging your creative
writing interests with your interesting
technology
I actually I never liked science fiction
growing up as a category I found uh it
was
why I was curious to me I started
becoming interested in physics and
metaphysics and astronomy and cosmology
was not from I I grew up with the
remnants of the Space Age kind of uh
filmatic universe and it never spoke to
me it always struck me as being
false somehow I should say that the work
I do on the side of being a philosopher
science is
uh really because there is no career
path
I found out at some point that doing all
this research it would lead me to
unemployment or frustration or just a
very marginalized existence I didn't
think that that was the right outlet for
this kind of research there's
philosophical thinking inform Your Grace
arising anyway they are in practice very
separated but I do believe that they're
they integrate on some level that I have
yet to quite see I was told before going
into philosophy and warned about ever
spending time doing philosophy is that
it's very intangible
knowledge it's not obvious how it can be
put into economic use for example and I
used to think that a lot of my studies
on you know logical and historical
foundations of how this came to be is
something that is of no particular value
to anyone
and then I realized as I engage more
with physicists community that they are
not trained in this kind of thinking at
all
and that there might be if there is
dialogue here there might be something
to contribute
thank you very much
thank you
for more debates talks and interviews
subscribe today to The Institute of Art
and ideas at IAI TV